a penniless Crimean woman weeps on the
steps of a kid social service office my
six-year-old daughter was in Crimea I
got her out using every method I could
all halu Nova was a children's clothing
designer in Crimea that was before the
disputed referendum last month that saw
her region break away from Ukraine and
become part of Russia she's one of
thousands who have fled 500 kilometers
north to the Ukrainian capital Kiev
because of concerns about ethnic tension
many stay in places like this a
crumbling soviet-era shelter there are
no luxuries here Alexandra and his son
left behind a two-room flat a car and
their lives although others which is we
left because we are Ukrainian citizens
we don't want to be Russians as i
understand it beginning april eighteenth
we'll all automatically become Russia
season gives social security workers are
helping eight thousand displaced
crimeans across the city new officers
have had to open up because of demand
about 900 people from Crimea have been
provided help and registered here since
the center opened different people some
with children some elderly people need
housing first and foremost but without
international assistance in a country
teetering on the brink of bankruptcy how
long can this help last Angus Bennett
Bloomberg